[Música]
seguramente todo que estás aquí sentado
ha sido víctima de este tipo de frases
que dicen no vas a poder
no lo intentes para que lo intentas
estás loco
es imposible
yo creo que a cada uno nos ha pasado
algo similar de ayudas si tú no toma las
decisiones no vas a poder hacer nada
entonces yo les voy a empezar a platicar
un poquito cómo es que juan alberto pues
obviamente desde que es niño en la
primera etapa de mi vida luchó para
tomar la decisión si vivir o morir a los
2 años tomó una botella de tyner no es
porque yo la quisiera tomar no tome la
decisión si tomármelo o no sino
simplemente me la tomé yo no sabía que
era peligroso estaba en una botella de
refresco y me la tomé sin embargo luche
en ese momento fue una decisión
involuntaria que yo tuve hay varios
tipos de decisiones que tú vas a tener
que tomar posteriormente pues obviamente
cuando empiezo a crecer cuando empiezo a
desarrollarme empiezan esos comentarios
principalmente en la familia de tus
papás que dicen hijo tú no tienes
talento no tienes habilidades para qué
quiere decir a fútbol para qué quieres
dibujar
para qué quieres ir a un curso de
robótica
por ejemplo bueno ahí es donde ellos
mismos nos empiezan a contagiar nos
empiezan a contaminar pero ya depende de
ti si tú tomas la decisión que qué es lo
que pasa bueno a los cuatro años dos
años después de que logré tomar la
decisión de quedarme en este mundo y de
vivir
qué pasa les digo a mis papás voy a
hacer un robot con cajas de cartón yo
quiero hacer un robot y ellos me dijeron
no vas a poder hijo cómo vas a hacer un
robot tomé cajas de cartón tomé una caja
de huevo
me metía adentro me lo puse como
transformers y ya había creado mi primer
robot y hablaba eh
cobraba el dinero en la papelería que
tenían mis papás ese robot obviamente ya
estaba dentro no pero para mí yo ya
había creado mi primer robot y estaba yo
feliz porque había hecho algo había
creado algo con mis propias manos
posteriormente
sigue sigue siguen pasando los años
estoy en la primaria en la secundaria y
entro a un grupo muy bueno de
paramédicos que son escuadrón de
servicios médicos y centro de rescate de
alta montaña obviamente yo soy de
escasos recursos no tenía yo dinero para
comprar mi equipo y nosotros tenemos la
oportunidad de ir a las primeras
expediciones al popocatépetl todavía se
podía subir a la malinche alista es
igual al pico de orizaba pero yo siempre
iba sin equipo entonces todos mis
compañeros me decían para que viene si
no tienes equipo nada más bien es
estorbar vienes a comerte la comida de
nosotros pero qué pasó en todas las
expediciones como pueden ver en la
imagen y vamos aproximadamente de 10 a
20 personas y en estas imágenes todo el
equipo que ven no era mío era de mis
compañeros tomé en ese momento la
decisión de decir lo voy a intentar
porque no yo quiero subir estas montañas
y decir que realmente hice el esfuerzo
cuál fue el resultado que de todos los
grupos en todas las ocasiones la primera
vez que subí hasta la cumbre
las montañas iba yo en la secundaria y
en la prepa en este periodo con el
equipo de los compañeros que se iban
quedando no los iban prestando a otro
compañero yo siempre llegaba con un
compañero más y les puedo decir que
gracias a eso pues tengo todas las
cumbres de mexico de las montañas este
principal es sin equipos sin dinero pero
con equipo prestado después alguien me
dijo una etapa más adelante cuando yo
tenía 25 años yo siempre quise ser
gimnasta pero obviamente desde la casa
de mis papás me decía no no tienes
habilidades no vas a poder a los 25 años
tomó la decisión de decir bueno voy a
intentarlo porque no y les puedo decir
que no soy un gran gimnasta pero si
puedo hacer ya bastantes cosas de
gimnasia y empecé a los 25 años una edad
totalmente imposible para todo aquel que
quiere ser gimnasta después yo tenía la
ilusión de tener una motocicleta
y obviamente me costó muchísimo trabajo
tardé diez años en juntar para comprarme
mi primer motocicleta pero también tomé
la decisión de hacer el guardadito y
obviamente tener el recurso para poder
comprarla diez años tarde es mucho
esfuerzo no a nada es fácil yo no estoy
diciendo que el tomar decisiones es
fácil es yo creo que lo más difícil que
cada uno puede hacer actualmente digo
también hago acrobacia soy stun de de
motocicletas y bien
paso a la siguiente etapa que es una de
las etapas más importantes de mi vida la
parte profesional que es lo que pasa en
la parte profesional yo les puedo decir
que orgullosamente soy guapa yo regresé
de la facultad de ciencias de la
electrónica y aquí en esta facultad
desde la primer semana surgió esa
inquietud vi un robot que yo lo vi
cuando era niño y demás es el robot don
cuco que seguramente muchos lo conocen
es un robot pianista
y en ese momento me viene una idea aguas
con esta palabra una idea
y digo bueno y porque no han hecho
robots desde don cuco voy a hacer un
robot llego a mi casa le digo mis papás
voy a hacer un robot me dicen estás loco
acabas de entrar a la carrera no lo vas
a poder hacer para no hacerle el cuento
tan largo creamos este robot que venden
leer en la primera imagen en la parte
superior era un robot teledirigido
control remoto en el primer mes en la
universidad si yo no tenía conocimientos
de electrónica sin embargo tomé la
decisión de hacerlo
participó en un congreso ganó el segundo
lugar y en ese congreso nos invitan a
participar en un evento de ciencia
y que fue lo primero que nos dijeron
bueno no participes en este evento de
ciencia para qué vas a participar para
qué vas a concursar pero antes déjenme
decirles que cuando creamos este robot
mi compañero y yo en ese momento en la
universidad éramos los más jóvenes todos
los demás que entraron a este programa
para desarrollar proyectos eran alumnos
de octavo o noveno semestre de maestría
que lo único que hacían es echarnos
tierra y decir para que les van a dar el
recurso a ellos para que les
desperdician su tiempo mejor de no los a
nosotros de los nueve proyectos que
participaron solamente el de nosotros
fue el que se concluyó por eso nos
mandaron a presentar nuestro proyecto en
el congreso de electrónica de ahí nos
invitan a participar este evento de
ciencias y estaba muy bien porque los
premios eran ir a eeuu a brasil a rusia
y realmente eso como que nos motivó pero
al mismo tiempo estábamos nosotros
desanimados porque porque en primera
nuestro asesor nos dijo todo está
arreglado ustedes no van a tener éxito
no entren para que entran y nuestros
compañeros no haya hicieron el robot ya
dejen de estar ahí jugando haciendo
tonterías mejor pónganse a estudiar que
van mal en la universidad y si digo yo
había reprobado cálculo en ese momento
no pero pero bueno aquí el punto es en
ese tome la decisión y dije bueno pero
porque nos dicen eso vamos a intentarlo
digo si nos están dando esta oportunidad
porque no la vamos a tomar
de ahí que nosotros participamos en este
evento de ciencia llega a la premiación
y no calificamos obviamente en nuestro
robot ni siquiera vislumbró entre los
ganadores estuvimos muy tristes tres
meses después una compañera bien me dice
oye felicidades ya sé que ganaste para
ir a rusia como que dejan el parián a
rusia si estás en internet que me voy
rápido a ver si efectivamente habíamos
ganado para ir a rusia sin embargo en
ese momento no nos habían mencionado en
la premiación bueno nosotros llegamos a
este evento en rusia es un evento
mundial muy grande participaron 87
países de ahí
para más de 10.000 participantes
estuvieron compitiendo en distintas
áreas distintas categorías en ese
momento surgió una anécdota que les voy
a contar que es precisamente de tomar
buenas decisiones a veces las decisiones
les dije son de distintas formas son
personales directas indirectas pero tú
tienes que tomar decisiones tienes que
saber qué decisión tomar y en el momento
preciso si en ese segundo decisivo tú no
tomas la decisión se puede pasar el
resto de tu vida nunca vas a saber si lo
pudiste hacer o no la anécdota que pasó
en este evento en moscú en rusia en el
año 2003 es que el robot un robot ruso
que estaba al lado de nosotros similar
al de nosotros se descompuso entonces
saben que el clásico mexicano pues somos
muy habilidosos nos nos damos ideas de
muchas formas les ayudamos y echamos a
andar su robot al final este robot queda
en primer lugar nosotros quedamos en
segundo pero de 87 países para nosotros
fue algo increíble primero nunca
pensamos pisar rusia después nunca
pensamos que vamos a ganar un premio
internacional fue el primero que tuvimos
de muchos
y se desprenden muchas cosas después nos
fuimos a brasil argentina uruguay chile
en total busy hemos recorrido desde ese
momento hasta ahora 32 países y hemos
dejado en alto el nombre de méxico y
todo fue porque por no hacer caso de los
comentarios de los demás tomar tú la
decisión personal y decir si lo voy a
hacer si puedo que no te importe en ese
momento si lo vas a poder hacer si
tienes el dinero si tienes el recurso si
tiene las ganas toma la oportunidad que
se te presenta si no tomas esa
oportunidad jamás jamás vas a hacer
cosas soy muy incisivo en este aspecto
porque es lo que muchos de nosotros
tenemos tú que estás aquí tú que estás
escuchando es porque realmente te
interesa tú ya has tomado una decisión
acertada el venir a un lugar donde vas a
escuchar a muchas personas que cada uno
en su vida han hecho cosas magníficas
han hecho cosas que quizás a muchos nos
parezcan inalcanzables sin embargo todo
es posible todo lo podemos hacer el
límite es tu imaginación por eso la
frase inicial decía nuestro espíritu
aventurero no conoce fronteras
de ahí obviamente pues se vienen muchos
premios muchas atribuciones por
gobernadores por instituciones
hace un año nos dan el premio del
ciudadano del año aquí les voy a
platicar una anécdota bastante fuerte
ese día que dan el premio del ciudadano
del año fue tan difícil el asistir a
este evento para recibir ese premio
porque anímicamente yo no me encontraba
bien ese día no teníamos ni siquiera
para comer así yo sé lo sé los platico y
yo me puse a pensar entre mí de esas
reflexiones que a veces nos hacemos
personalmente y decimos bueno cómo es
posible que tengo tantos premios he
visitado tantos países hoy me dan un
premio bastante importante ciudadano del
año no cualquiera se luego se lo dan
nunca pensé tenerlo tampoco y no tenemos
hoy para comer que difícil no y tener
una sonrisa en ese momento ante las
cámaras ante todo méxico recibir el
premio y tú sabes está por adentro que
tu familia no tiene para comer pero qué
pasa si no hubiera ido a esa recepción
del premio pues también hubiera estado
mal no entonces hay decisiones que
dependen mucho también de los factores
externos que nosotros tenemos no se
dejen llevar por
lo que pasa afuera de su entorno déjense
llevar por lo que pasa aquí y
principalmente por lo que está acá si
entonces si ustedes tienen esa
determinación estoy seguro que van a
cambiar su forma de vida su forma de
pensar su forma de ver las cosas que
actualmente como bien decía él
el doctor que introdujo aquí a ted
ustedes son la generación del cambio
están cambiando una era entonces ustedes
son los responsables de todo lo que
viene atrás lo que vamos a vivir
nosotros empezando por acá en méxico y
bueno una de las partes más importantes
o mejores que me han pasado
después de todo esto les puedo platicar
mil cosas pero nos vamos a concretar en
una
afortunadamente en rusia tuve una
relación muy cercana desde el primer
momento que pisé rusia fue el primer
país que conocí
entonces empiezo a hacer muchas
relaciones y actualmente les puedo decir
porque soy profesor en las dos
principales universidades en moscú que
es la universidad estatal de moscú y la
universidad pedagógica de moscú unas
científicos y otras profesores porque
soy director de la
de lo que es la expedición científica
ruso mexicana porque estoy candidateado
a ser cosmonauta por la agencia espacial
rusa cómo es que juan alberto llega
hasta este punto de la nada de todo lo
que más o menos ahorita les platiqué
bueno pues precisamente es eso el tomar
buenas decisiones poco más que llegó a
la agencia espacial cuando yo estoy
estudiando el doctorado en rusia estudio
un doctorado en física en la nota en
biomédica en robótica aplicada a la
medicina no se asusten de ahí
y nos envían a hacer prácticas a la
agencia espacial rusa obviamente yo
empiezo a indagar y ven que el mexicano
es muy bueno porque todos me dicen el
mexicano no me dicen juan alberto ni
sabían mi nombre todo dice el mexicano
no hablarle al mexicano hablarle al
mexicano les puedo decir que por manos
mexicanas estas que están viendo aquí
ahorita actualmente hay vuelos al
espacio tripulados contribuimos
precisamente en la actualización de lo
que es toda la electrónica del sayús el
sello es la cápsula donde van los
cosmonautas de ahí obviamente empezamos
a hacer muchos trabajos como prácticas
obviamente yo era yo estudiante pero se
empiezan a fijar los rusos que hay un
mexicano que pues tiene habilidad no con
las manos sin habilidad intelectual de
ahí surgen muchos proyectos yo regreso a
mexico voy a rusia etcétera y tengo que
tomar la decisión
de regresar a rusia por una razón hay un
proyecto entre rusia y méxico y dicen
necesitamos un cosmonauta mexicano
quiere serlo ustedes que hubieran dicho
si no en este momento yo me enfrentaba
una decisión difícil porque porque mi
esposa es rusa la conocí en el primer
evento la conocí en la primera vez que
fui a rusia actualmente ya está conmigo
está aquí en méxico estoy muy contento
muy feliz pero ella me dijo si tú eres
cosmonauta yo no quiero un esposo
cosmonauta nos separamos era una
decisión difícil entonces no les voy a
poder platicar el desenlace lo vamos a
dejar para la siguiente pero si les
puedo decir cuál viene la lección para
todos ustedes cuál es la elección hay
tres tipos de personas la persona
mediocre es la que actualmente habla
solamente de las redes sociales se burla
a costa de los demás con los memes está
todo el tiempo en la computadora no
estudia etcétera te identificás aguas la
persona normal es la que precisamente
pues está en sus en su esfera en su zona
de confort todos le dan sus papás
plática de lo que le van la escuela
al cine con sus compañeros es tan normal
se la lleva relax no se desgasta por
hacer algo diferente
si estás en este caso también no está
mal pero piénsalo y viene la persona
intelectual todos los que vamos a estar
aquí frente a ustedes son personas
intelectuales tú qué quieres ser la
persona intelectual es la que cree
principalmente en sus ideales la que
lucha por conseguir sus metas la que no
ve alguna alguna o algún obstáculo para
poder llegar a esa frontera que su
espíritu interno llegue hasta donde no
se ve el límite esa es la persona
intelectual la persona que cree en sí
misma que no le importa lo que digan los
demás entonces ahí viene la elección
para cada uno de nosotros de ustedes que
están aquí en este momento
lo que quiere ser te invito a que seas
una persona mediocre chile en tu
teléfono sigue lea y riéndote de los
memes riéndote de la foto que le toma
hasta tu compañero y le escribiste hoy
es día de fiesta hoy es viernes y está y
bailando sigue teniendo de eso sea una
persona mediocre te invito a que lo seas
si quiere ser una persona normal también
tengo la invitación no te salgas de tu
esfera no te salgas de tu zona de
confort quédate allí
deja que todo llegue que te den de comer
tus papás que termines la universidad si
puedes que termine la escuela pase este
examen quédate ahí pero si quieres
realmente cambiar tu vida tomar la
decisión que va a cambiar tu vida sea
una persona intelectual cree en ti mismo
cree en tus ideales cree en lo que vas a
llegar que tu espíritu aventurero no
conozca fronteras la decisión está en ti
una vez que termines de estas de estas
charlas ted tú vas a tener la decisión
porque cambiará tu vida y la mejor
decisión la tienes tú la tienes tú y tu
eres el que vas a decidir qué vas a
hacer con tu vida muchas gracias
[Música]